we have a sad day today Walter brown
passed away couple days ago
as far as you're concerned at home about
five days ago
am i right oh man six days ago and I
just saw Walter in Vegas and have a lot
of Vegas stories but as they say what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas Walter
was a colleague of mine and we played
several times over the last 30 years and
he was only 66 years old I saw Walter a
few years ago in Vegas my son there
almost every year and he sounded and
looked sort of strange and I was like
that's not the Walter I know and turned
out he had throat cancer and he had
surgery and supposedly he was all better
and a year or two later he was looking
better and talking better and acting
like his old self so actually it was
quite a shock that I heard yesterday
that he passed not only did he play in
the national open and win a prize he
also taught at the chest camp that I
taught at right before the tournament
and he gave a simultaneous which was
well very odd because in a twenty five
board simultaneous I was told by the
organizer it took him six and a half
hours which is I mean I guess if I give
a thousand board sign will take six and
a half hours but just says like when I'm
giving a sample I sort of run around and
Walter tries to play perfect every moves
very competitive and even though his
opponents are much lower rated usually
by about a thousand points he still
might take three or four minutes a move
and try to play the perfect move I mean
he was like that he didn't didn't play
for fun he played for blood he played
for the maximum result and as a result
he won six US Championships he won 11
national opens and he was known as the
king of the Swiss which is a funny title
for somebody who won six US championship
because those are round robins so Walter
brown and his best was a top 20 player
in the world the last 10 or 20 years he
was one of the top 20 players in the US
lately was obviously wasn't as strong as
it used to be being in his mid 60's
although he is the reigning u.s. senior
champion and he's still a very feared
opponent scoring three out of four and
the national open this year the four
players that he played losing only to a
grandmaster who was much higher rated
him and the guy I posted some of these
stories on social media but I want to
tell him here very few players when I
say very few probably just Walter
probably nobody has results of games
overturned however in the two instances
I know maybe there's more where Walters
game finished a result was recorded that
result was later changed I played him in
the subsequent round in both of those
occasions and I don't maybe he had other
games overturned but those are the two I
know what was it the 87 US Open in
Portland Oregon
you had me talking to Julian and he had
lost to love Albert with the black
pieces and he played the game under
protest because he was given three black
pieces in a row which at the time was
specifically forbidden in the rulebook
you may not have three blacks in a row
not like you shouldn't you can't and
that rule is ridiculous but that was the
rule and so the directors were like that
rules ridiculous so this gave him three
blacks in a row played the game under
protest
it's the US Opens everybody from the US
CF is there they agree with Walter that
it was an egregious pairing when the
term was over they awarded him three
quarters of a point for that game okay
very suspicious and he got second prize
as a result not taking away prizes from
the other players who also got second so
everybody got second except me anyway I
played Walter in the last round was the
first
I played Brown I was rated 2,400 maybe
and we drew I was black I was much worse
the whole game then he hung upon that it
was equal so if I didn't like hanging
upon probably like getting three blacks
in a row so we drew the next time was
also I seemed in Vegas on I was in Las
Vegas Walter had a work at night against
a rook at a pawn and they've been
playing for six or seven hours and his
opponent claimed to draw due to
insufficient losing chances the arbiter
agreed and the game was declared to draw
following morning the organizer in chief
TD Bill Goldberg woke up was told of
this and said that's the wrong ruling it
was the wrong ruling found the other guy
made them pull out the game in Walter
won and then I played Walter in the last
round and he gave me the beat down I
then lost to Walter in the 94 US
Championship in Key West my first US
Championship I'm showing you I'm gonna
show you that guy in this lecture and I
beat Walter last year national open in
the last round the only time I ever beat
him also I'm going to show that game
it's a very strange Walter has a very
good friend named Ron grosse and in fact
Ron's a master Ron's in his late 70s
he's still over 2,200 and Walter was at
Ron's place sleeping when Ron found him
and couldn't wake him up
a few days ago and the paramedics came
in and pronounced him dead when they
when they got there I played Ron gross
in round one of last year's national
open and I played Walter in the last
round so life is a strange thing
I played Walter here just a few months
ago at the Chess Club in the last round
now we were both exhausted we played a
quick draw I have black against Walter
every game we've ever played my son also
played Walter Brown in that tournament
here at the Chess Club and my son also
drew and he was white so my son's had
white every game against Walter I've had
black every game one of my son's only
played in once and another fine gold
connection which I haven't told it
lately in the nineteen late 1960s early
1970s Walter brown was playing
stress in New York and he had a game
going with my dad and ASA Hoffman and
bran was very young then I think my dad
said he was between 15 and 18 and they
were better than Brown and blitz chess
at that point probably when he got into
his early 20th there wasn't really a
match anymore so Feingold's have been
playing Brown for quite a long time I've
seen him at over 20 tournaments and I've
seen him in st. Louis I've seen him in
Vegas I see him in Key West
I've seen him everywhere US
Championships and I only beat him to one
time but unlike a lot of grandmasters
today he always fought to the bitter end
and even as he advanced in age most of
his games were very sharp now I gave a
lecture earlier in the Chess Club a
month ago
and I tried to show a game I believe it
was Viktor Korchnoi I'm awaiting the
crazy comments on YouTube saying it
wasn't questioning it was this guy I
think it was course knowing where I
showed a game that he played every
decade that course not
okay so you guys can't complain and I
did the same with Brown I found the
games he played in the 60s 70s 80s 90s
2000s and 2010's in his last rated game
was against Hans demon who's also been
at the Chess Club he's a top junior
player
Walter won that game and I actually
couldn't find that game on the internet
I was surprised because I wanted to show
that game but anyway so in the 60s
actually Brown played in six Olympiads
two for Australia and four for the US
and I wanted to show games he won
against American players because you're
more familiar with them in general and
Walter was born in Australia one of his
parents was American and one was
Australian and then he moved to the US
shortly thereafter being brought up in
New York
eventually living in California and
becoming a semi professional poker
player we have a mutual friend who's
very good at a lot of games Bob Shefali
Bob chiffon he's known for coming in
third the World Series of Poker
Bob and Walter were very good friends
and Bob told me a lot of stories about
Walter and sometimes Bob isn't very kind
about other players and other games he
sort of tells it like it is
so when I found out that Walter was a
poker player
I thought Bob Schiavoni would say well
he plays poker but not very good that's
what I was expecting
instead Bob said he's an excellent
player and even better than Bob in
certain kinds of poker so Brown has
cashed over 200,000 and turned him to
poker winnings he's cashed a lot more
than that in chess winnings and he was a
real character really going to miss him
all right so first game was against
James Tarjan I think it's apt because it
was a night off so in case my comer
walks in we better better flip the board
okay well Brown was one of the world's
leading authorities in the niner of
Sicilian tar Jones another player I'm
talking to a legends about at some point
he basically quit chests for 30 years
and now he's back well he's not as good
as you used to be but he's pretty good
huh
Tarzan's playing chess again okay so we
have a night off Sicilian theory in the
60s obviously different than it is now
but I mean Brown was the world's leading
theoretician basically along with Bobby
Fischer and they played a very sharp
line which is still being played today
age six is pretty rare most grandmasters
are playing Queen c7 now our night
Beauty seven in Queen c7 now the idea of
age six is something that became very
popular in the 70s black plays an early
g5 with the idea of getting control of
the e5 square and this is actually a
model game to show how to do that even
though it was 1968 h4 and eventually
Bishop c4 is not a good move it's not a
good square for the bishop normally in
these positions the bishops going to d3
weren't safe and of course white has
intentions of
you know sacking everything on e6 and
now g5 has played quickly I'm guessing
since it was 1968 Tarja may not have
been familiar with the g5 idea the idea
is not to play crazy g5 Matt Larson
style because it was 1968
the idea is to gain control of e5 and
that's what Brown did so he took 95 the
bishop is badly placed on c4 obviously
the queen is attacked ok and now again I
move you wouldn't suspect unless you
know the variation in Knight to g4 and
nine to g4 pins the G pawn to the bishop
now this is a very common idea in
Sicilian in 1968 not so much and
basically black has everything black
dominates e5 black has more pawns in the
center black staying at the open H bow
for his rook and White's just getting
pushed back and this is just not not
good at all for a white queen is
defending the night the night is
stopping white from castling luckily
this isn't a beginner class it would
take me hours to explain why white can
castle
hopefully my club ring is not paying
attention okay Queens attacking b2 as in
most Sicilians
Knight to d1 pretty meek and E 5 is an
excellent move normally e5 is super ante
positional recommended by Julian however
here it's not because we're destroying
this Bishop on g3 we're killing the
knight on f3
there's no squares for these pieces
unless you like getting captured and our
Bishop on the light square is great now
and the most important to explain why
it's not an SI positional is when it is
anti positional white is playing Knight
to d5 and black is crying if white plays
Knight to d5 here then the arbiter left
to show up because this Knights not
going to d5 ever so there's no drawbacks
'if I've and now that the D pawn is no
longer attacked we can start taking
stuff
this should have to forcing the taking
of stuff Browns like thanks and taking
more stuff okay and basically Black has
the two bishops and black has the two
extra pawns I don't know what I like
more two extra bonds okay all right so
there's nothing going on Black's just
have two pawns and white has nothing and
plenty of it now three extra pawns and
okay white resigned White's down three
pawns and he can't move anything that
was sort of an embarrassing loss for
chargin who is actually played in the
intra zonal and had yes or Sarah won as
a second this game it looks like a sign
will get why just black just took all
the pawns and that's because Brown
really understood what was going on in
the night ourf and this was probably one
of the first games where the ideas of g5
95 and 94 came to fruition and white
looked really bad why just got totally
pushed back okay that was the 60s now we
go to the 70s this is another player
that I often see in Vegas Anthony Sadie
and this tournament was venturous 71
although it says us challenge of 72
Inventure 71 so this game was played in
two different years okay now venture is
71 as you all know was the US Open and I
know that because my dad played there
and my good friend Wes Berger and they
were paired came from Michigan to play
in the US Open actually we lived in
California when I was a little kid
71 sounds about right because I had a
tracheotomy UCLA when I was two I was
born in 69 I turned 2 in September of 71
so we might have gone to the tournament
that moved out there maybe maybe that
happened I don't know I was - what do
you want from me okay so this is brown
versus Sadie Sadie played a mini US
Championships in the 60s quite a strong
player
and brown is white so I got to flip the
board again there we go
now Brown used to only play e4 and play
for the Smackdown then you only play d4
then you only play d4
I think lately is playing e4 like you
sort of change his mind so this is the
60s 70s early 70s they played a lot of
theory to caro-kann a lot of theory
still theory today this games about as
old as I am now this is still like the
mainline now I mean nowadays blacks
castling King side and getting
checkmated but in the old days they
Castle queenside didn't get checkmated
see the improvements we've had now we
get checkmated and I Castle queenside so
I've had this position now Brown played
Queenie to a 95 which is not played
today nowadays we play 94 and then white
plays either g3 Bishop f4 or pushes his
King side pawns Queen e2 at 95 is very
rare then why plate f4 Bishop to e7
somewhat passive King b1 it looks like a
Carroll Khan you'd see today c4 is very
important all these Carroll Khan's
to basically kill the Black Knight Black
Knight has nowhere to go and white just
has space on both sides of the board ok
black gets pseudo aggressive not really
any threats and then he's like oh well I
guess my 984 wasn't very good now to be
honest with you it's hard to understand
the moves Knight a4 to b6 something
didn't work out something wasn't flowing
a3 and unfortunately when you move your
queen a lot sometimes your opponent
takes it especially when it gets trapped
on the side of the board Bishop c5 is an
excellent move trying to get rid of the
dark squared bishop so my knight can hop
into g6 and black just can't do anything
and black resigned black can play queen
a5 if he doesn't want to lose his Queen
and then he loses his Queen life stuff
so when your Queens on the side of the
board you can get trapped probably Sadie
overlooked this because he was probably
really worried about this night coming
in here and I understand that's pretty
worrisome and he's probably so worried
about that he forgot about his own queen
getting trapped a little B and I think
that's why you played King ba he could
try to kick the night out and Knight d6
wouldn't be check but he just forgot his
queens getting trapped
so after Knight c5 he's like oh my
Queens getting trapped and when I put
this on the engine earlier it suggested
Queen takes rook so that's good time
your design and Brown was known for as a
great tactician he was also known for
his behavior on the chess board sort of
shaking a lot and he in type trouble
this is also a great positional player
that because everything if you want to
be world class okay here's a game
against Patrick wolf that was played in
the u.s. championship in the 80s and
well yes sir probably wouldn't agree
with me treci if I agree with myself I'm
trying to figure out was Brown at his
peak in the 70s or 80s yeah we'll go
with you late seventies early eighties
okay well like yes or way in later and
you at home okay so Walter play D for D
for then D for the knee for this is the
D for period and wolf played the Benko
now Patrick wolf played every bed
opening he could find the Benko and and
the the grünfeld Wow they're probably
okay but if I was wolf I would have pled
the grünfeld against Brown so I think
wolf led led the grenfell pretty well
wolf was also an uncompromising player
so times you get beat fast okay now what
brown did this game was he just went
forward
he didn't you know his book is like
finesse and you know but no finesse
Brown did this this game he just went
like that and will find like that okay
and then the so I took a picture it was
great so I mean I would play Bishop
takes e4 without thinking and if I did
think I would play like Knight d2 takes
e4
I usually don't think but he five four
are okay that's that's the way Brown
played okay he played the most
aggressive and calculated really well
rookie 198 yeah I'm not a fan
ninety-eight Bishop f4 yeah I mean why
it's just killing it here White has all
his pieces in the center works on e1
black has weak pawns everywhere
blacks Queen sides terrible I mean just
terrible position for black and you know
Brown didn't didn't play twenty Musa
Theory all the time sometimes he just
played really aggressively and he won
quickly now I was interviewed earlier
today
yeah what's today wow I've lost
something it yeah
because today was the way you don't know
this because you're at home and you're
confused of course you were confused
before this video now you're more
confused today was the last day in
Norway and after moves seven I was like
what's Magnus doing playing terrible f6
yeah and I was like hammers going to win
everybody laughed at me including Hammer
hammer colleagues I'm like repeat Magnus
click anyone so yeah I mean you know
anyway yeah so I was being interviewed
and I was I was talking about Brown and
you know all the good stuff he did and
sometimes is wild and crazy pipe and I
mean sometimes he played 20 25 moves of
Fury tonight orphe and sometimes there's
move six or seven he played something
you wanted to play and got you out of
your game and beat you that way okay 96
the point of 98 and 9 takes f7 and I
would assume
you what am I going to assume yeah I'm
going to assume wolf didn't see this not
that he underestimated it because with
the 996 there's no Knight f7 so you
probably just like a knight f7 is not
happening and I'm going to play Knight
d4 and I'm going to show the world how
to maneuver my knight and then Knight
takes f7 it's a little more brutal
okay so Rick takes looks a lot safer
than King takes d6 against either move
and I mean if I was giving a Paul Morphy
lecture I would explain how white is
crashing through and playing
aggressively because black isn't moving
any of his pieces that's a good time to
do it okay
now White's not threatening Bishop takes
rook
although Bishop takes rook is a big
threat the mysteries of life I mean pawn
takes pawn is also really good Wow is
that good if you were better at chess at
home you know how good that is
yeah high raise you are the more good
you think it is so if you really like
fun now you're good player if you're
like what why is you doing that then and
ambition takes rook and Queen b3 check
also good anyway wolf is pretty strong
player so e six blocking all the threats
Bishop e6 once again we're going to take
King tags Queen b3 check winning the
bishop so Bishop c6 94 possibly 95 as a
threat anyway that these are some good
defensive pieces over here 9 to d4
attacking the bishop on e6 check Knight
takes e5 and even though white
sacrificed with 9 takes f7 who's ahead
in material here yeah white so white
kept taking stuff
take it all these pawns taking the rook
and blacks King not so good there's good
and there's not good the King is not
good okay and we got a passed pawn on d6
rookie 7 check doesn't look dangerous if
you're white you're black it looks
dangerous
okay so wolf stop crook e7 check by
making it
check rope to see one again and more if
you like move rook on a one does nothing
sort of like the goggles of The Simpsons
they do nothing and now the rook is you
know really strong
you would think black would want to
develop his nighttime ba but that just
weakens the bishop on c6
okay so Bishop to d5 wolf is the master
of the one square Bishop of Bishop d7 to
c6 to d5 Knight to b3 now we're ready
for both rooks to come to the seventh
takes takes and finally completes
development rook to e7 and I think this
is where he blundered Bishop f6 no I
think he was like minus 30s it didn't
matter Bishop to e3 and now the simple
calculation of takes and taking and then
whites up two pawns and winning so you
can't take the rook play Knight f5
allowing the Queen to go to g5 on the
other hand the knight on g4 is attacked
so I don't know
resigning you can't you can't let it
take the knight and you can't move the
knight the chess is tough so you moved
it anyway and I guess you could take the
knight on g7 first but Brau made it
easier Queen d5 check and the queen is
overworked so wherever the King moves
rook takes Knight is going to win lots
of pieces a real dominating performance
in the 80s by Brown over I mean Patrick
Wolf won the US Championship I believe
twice again go to youtube and say he did
when it's Weiss what are you talking
about whether you wanted twice I got to
tell you a funny story related to wolf
because I'm telling all these brown
stories I gave one of the my private
students Ian Arbor Michigan I lived in
Ann Arbor for seven years one of my
private students is his dad was a lawyer
and law school professor actually and
after about seven months of teaching him
going to his house his mom said like
yeah I was a lawyer but I I stopped and
he said you were a lawyer so she went to
Harvard Law School he didn't know and he
was like 14 so that was the beginning of
the next part of the story yeah I went
to Harvard Law School and I dated a guy
who was really good at chess and I've
heard that before and I was like
Julien's the answer okay anyway I was
like so who did you date when you went
to Harvard Law School and she said
Patrick wolf and I was like oh well he
was the US Champion so yeah so he did so
yeah so that was funny she had seen
Patrick wolf and she was a Harvard Law
School graduate and her son was like
what okay um a related story I was
teaching a chess class in Arbor and
usually the kids are like my dad's the
world champion and my mom came in second
and my uncle was the referee and you
know and and I'm gonna be on next know
anyway so this kid says my my uncle is a
chess master and I said who's your uncle
and he said Greg small and Greg smalls a
chess master so that kid was right and
not only is Greg small a chess master I
believe he's the tallest chess master in
the u.s. his aim small six foot seven so
yeah stated the chess masters Uncle John
tall was short short is tall and small
as the tallest I already gave you all
that you know you messed it all up
typical then whom small six seven
Larson's like six - you're the worst
maybe Larson 6 - well this has edited so
you don't see how I'm Julian is
six - you think is 7 feet tall I plant
in the Cleveland open about 10 years ago
and the guy was so tall I asked him how
tall he was which I do like once every
two years that he said seven feet so he
was tall he had a giant chess clock - I
mean it was yeah one round he played a
kid he was like two feet tall that was
funny all right
so brownie I draw yeah hi
now unfortunately I played Walter brown
the 1994 US Championship fortunately was
in Key West which was nice and I have a
funny story from Key West also and I
like stories
there was a rest day and we're all
sitting in the hot tub maybe like half
the players and Boris crybaby crimen
said Ben do you know where Kim Bishop
versus rock and I was born in America so
no and I said no he says oh what kind of
professional are you what if what I said
well I guess I should know it but it's
never going to happen and if it does
happen it'll either cost me half a point
in my life or a Wong so I don't waste my
time with that I'm here not dub okay
anyway the next day this is this
tournament
I played nigde fermion and I had rook
against wrecking Bishop for the first
time in my life when I sing and man I'm
going to hear about it but I drew about
15 years later I put it in the table
base and I was always drawing the week
after that I played in Chicago against
international master Josh Mannion and I
had rook and Bishop versus rook and he
didn't know how to draw and I won those
are the only two times I had in my life
were a week apart right after the guy
asked me in the hot tub so so don't ask
me those questions I don't get these I
don't want to get these these positions
all right now playing Brown and I used
to play this very suspicious opening
some call it the Baltic defense and some
called the Estonian Defence Paul Kara's
would play it occasionally I played all
the time you basically play Bishop f5 on
move taro and you hope not to lose in 10
moves now I've played it a lot so I do
some of the ins and outs we played one
of the main lines that this is the way I
play with white now Queen a4 check and
you can play rook takes b1
but he took and in this position if I
well I've had white in this position
more than I've had black actually
because if you play the Baltic this is
what I do
Queen takes pawn is I think very
necessary here but I was young much
younger than I am now so I always played
for tricks I play d5 I mean he's not
falling for the trick but you know you
would so I mean I played e5 then that's
what I did and actually this is a
position I show a lot of my private
students I just set this up and I say
what should white play and sometimes I
like their answer and sometimes I don't
now e5 has a threat and the threat isn't
the d4 pawn the threat is Bishop to b4
check and if you play takes you're
really going to not like this should be
for Chuck because you're you have to
take it was your queen okay but Brown
played the best to move which is for
white which is stop push it before Chuck
a little more a little more aggressive
than that only a little you Bishop yeah
or this this thing always happens to me
Bishop to d2 right okay now again if I
had this position again I would play
queen's eggs d4 which I think I did
actually
yeah and now I will play Knight takes d4
by took with a pawn now Brown did
something very nice I'm very
appreciative as a positional player he
played the move in this position Knight
h3 which I was really impressed with
because the knight doesn't really want
to go to f3 then I wants to go to f4 and
then either d5 or d3 depending on the
situation now this is the kind of
position I dream about you may dream
about different stuff but I drew about
isolated pawn and two bishops
unfortunately I'm black here so okay and
Brown ended the game very nice
tactically positionally I'm just losing
he has two bishops and I have a weak
pawn and I have like no counter play and
the end of the game was very nice rook
takes is very nice obviously sees I
missed that it looks like something I
would miss
yeah and the very end of the game was
really nice play the movie three and is
getting like a technical win because I
made this mistake on c6 and I tried to
play tricky with the move Bishop c3 so I
was hoping for something like takes
takes here and then I would get left and
then you know we would trade these pawns
and this is a book drop and I probably
have lost if it's a book drop okay so I
was hoping for something like that but
after Bishop c3 he played a very nice
tactical move which the screen already
showed but you weren't paying attention
you would some crazy answer that's the
louder
he takes d4 now all my pieces are
hanging just when I got him into my trap
there and here I resigned if I take that
he made Smee and wins the exchange and
if I do nothing I lose everything so I
got to take this now he Queens which
isn't good and if I play Bishop takes d4
then Bishop d2 to e3
yeah that's drunk bishops to him pretty
good actually
yeah and I just lose so after after he
takes d4 I resigned
yeah that's first decisive game I had I
had with with Walter 1994 US
Championship unfortunate for me another
funny story about that tournament I
played a lot of tennis that tournament
I played Quaeda knov and and shabal
ah've and brown brown was by far the
best and before he plays like he's like
no you're good okay because I I can't
play if you're not good and I was like
yeah I'm pretty good and then I wasn't
good oh now there was a woman at the
tournament who was like helping out she
was a friend of a friend and she was the
southern Florida women's tennis champion
which is like would be like the best in
the world because all the best players
in Florida and brown brown
her Brown was pretty good tennis player
surprising anyway that was the 90s this
is the 2000s now this is a term I've
never played in it's in South America
every every year and I'd never been to
South America so hopefully I'll go to
this tournament at some point it's the
continental championship you take all
the Americans even Central America you
hear me talking Alejandro then and this
was played you know somewhere in South
America between brown and Yuri Schulman
two Americans playing and the purpose of
this event is the top four or five go to
the intra zonal kind of tournament
whatever that is what are they calling
another World Cup whatever they do now
that's yeah so a lot of the strong
American grandmasters go there and hope
to qualify ok Brown's white in the Kings
Indian Browns head white and a lot of
kings Indians and normally Browns
playing the classical variation with
Knight f3 and Bishop e2 but here he
played the same ish I guess it's all the
same as to him exactly like I played
you're a showman in 2001 I think you
played Fred utd at that point ok and
they play some sandwich theory and if
somehow you can see the ratings and you
can I'm sure Ben Simon with his magic
will show you what the ratings are their
feeder ratings 25 68 for Schulman 2447
for brown Brown didn't care what his
rating was you can cure your rating was
he played for a win and that's why he
was so beloved and why he wants so many
tournaments he played chess he didn't
play his opponents rating wasn't afraid
of anybody
he didn't think people were oh he's
better than me so now if we could take a
funnier example and I guess if John
Fodor would cease just gonna punch me
next time but I'll be ready and I see
John every year so I'm going to be in
trouble if he watches this John Fedora's
is sort of the opposite John was the
biggest fighting player I've ever seen
the last ten years not so much okay ten
move draw might be a little too long in
some of his games
anyway I remember in the US championship
in 2007 or 2008 in Tulsa Oklahoma anyway
yeah sorry I'm thinking about Tulsa
Oklahoma and I can't talk anymore all
right
fedora is playing Shulman same Schulman
we see here and there was a rule no
draws before 30 moves unless there was a
really good reason really good reason so
in round one
Coleman's playing Fedora wits and
Schulman offers a draw really early 1819
and Fedora which says the GAR from you
drawn I want to take it I have a really
good reason I met her like what said
he's a lot better than me and they were
like okay and draw yeah he's better than
me I want to draw okay well Brown would
ever do that if Brown thought he was
point zero zero one better he's playing
for the win okay against two
supercomputers with Carlson controlling
them is especially the Carlson now now I
play for the win there Carlson now man
I'm ready okay anyway so Brown played
very aggressive with white especially
with white and they played this crazy
Kings Indian everybody's playing for a
win that's what you Americans do and
eventually Brown just like in his game
talk slowly bent so you can figure it
out with Patrick Wolf yes okay I spoke
very slowly so I could figure out it was
plays d5 y e5 and plays for the win
what who all right and Ricky eight
instead of taking it now of course
this is the famous Benoni maneuver where
after Eve five and they take it what do
you play
f5 and now it's difficult for blacks to
play Knight e5 or Bishop e5 for
illegality reasons and now White's got
94 and Bishop takes c5 and and yeah and
blacks pieces are here terrible
so Schulman is like you can't trick me
with that I'm going to play that I'm
going to play rook e8 and Brown plays
rook d1 is like no no take it come on
and this next reminds me of the wolf
game also where Brown played were Kade
is c1 the only piece that wasn't doing
anything now we're K to d1 and f5 and
well blacks apana but his pawn is
blocking all of his pieces and whites
you know shoving his F pawn up and I
can't say anything because we're being
filmed but can imagine what I want to
say all right so II for getting the pawn
out the way how the Bishop is a little
better FG FG 94 black black 1 upon gave
it back and now White has a passed pawn
on d6 White has domination of the d5
square with everything and blacks pieces
are all terrible so White's
strategically winning but it's sort of
it looks like Abba donees that's what he
gets
Nigel short would be proud of me 97
track a little tactics Queen takes if
the something takes the knight let's say
queen guy figured that out takes takes
check some move man I don't know what
move you some move is uh I resign so
Queen takes is I was gonna I was going
to make a queen but why can't even get
that far and Bishop takes a similar
there's uh the others yeah yeah okay so
he took the Pawnee seven now there's no
queening okay ninety-six and white is up
material and whites threatening
everything Queen check everywhere
Queen take g6 rook f7 and whites up
material man awesome night f8 always
play 9 f8 rook e1 threading bishop
everywhere Queen c4 check Bishop f4
but I do not resign all right Rick DEA
Knight f5 discovered attack on the Queen
Bishop d4 check rook takes d4 discovered
attack on the Queen Bishop takes rook
check and it is very fitting that black
gets track mated very fitting and mate
yeah you redo this against me too come
on Yuri Victoria talked to Yuri I was
meeting Yuri here because I won't move
before mate he did here to just get
mated come on man the people that people
want to see it they don't want you to
like one move before mate come on man oh
man that would really make him furious
now if you know my game with my match
with Rey Robson where I lost every game
I didn't resign like I made it I'm well
yeah then once he made all right got my
appearance fee either way all right now
to finish off the lecture with the game
from the 2010s a game I wanted against
Walter yay I showed him okay and this
was in the last round of the National
Open I think it was a it was some kind
of lizard a chameleon yeah so you think
I'm cracking up here which I am but I'm
still right before this game he was
doing some kind of promotion for his
chest that he invented some variants and
he had like a reptile with him I think
it was a chameleon and he's like we get
a picture they put the chameleon on the
board and we were sitting like this for
his thing
yeah not scared yeah yeah yeah but he
had some can be it some lizard yeah a
true story
yeah you can't make this stuff up look a
on the Internet I was scared too I was
like this lizards going to attack me
alright so Walter was white and we
played the Sicilian line that I knew
from the game Carlson golf and even
though Carlson won like I've had this
position several times I never know
to do by new carlson golf pants and I
knew what to do and unlike golf it I
didn't lose okay and I didn't know what
to do anymore this out my prep ok these
moves are okay whites a little bit
better I actually had this later in the
year in the last round in Charlotte
North Carolina against Casa Corley and I
want a worse position very similar to
this yam Brown quite rookie 3a move I
never considered then I was like that's
a good move I'm pins is night rooks
going to g3 and d3 yeah okay rook d3
this should be six now this could get
quite embarrassing if he Pleasant move
like rook to da track then I have to go
for a walk in fact I psych for a moment
just for a moment
calm down at home calm down sit down
said I I considered this and then after
this I'm in a little trouble because if
I go here he mates me then the troubles
over and if I go here Bishop c5 is
reasonable yeah so I was like okay whoa
I'll fly Bishop takes Knight hit this
could be an embarrassing last round so I
whoa so I played Bishop e7 defending d8
somewhat making my bishop before look
quite stupid and okay we played and he
was a little better but I defended
defended defended this ending is a draw
but White's a little better now one of
Walter Browns problems is a chess player
which everybody knows he's always in
time trouble now his other problem which
isn't really a problem but it wasn't
this game Brown doesn't like to draw and
he doesn't like if he thinks he's better
to to give a draw he wants to fight so
this probably should be a draw but Brown
went too far and I've done that myself
normally when true grandma Esther's are
playing if there's a rating disparity
the higher rated Grandmaster
go too far but Brown considers himself
an elite grandmasters one of the top 20
in the world just not anymore and he
knows who I am so he's like oh boy then
fine gold in the last round now on the
other hand if you don't know who we are
look at our ratings I'm a lot higher
rated so you would think he wouldn't go
too far but he didn't character rating
was he wanted to win so he he played
Matt Larsen style unfortunately he had
the same result man Larsen would have
against man it's unfortunate alright and
Brown was in his usual time trouble and
I moved 40 he made a bad move
happens in time trouble this should just
be a draw but he's still playing for the
win we got this position and here okay I
played rugby seven night a four he's
pushing pushing pushing for the win
wants to play 95 King f6 very good move
King f6 is good because now rook takes
pawn is in check so now he's not
threatening rook takes pawn because I
have 96 check and he didn't seem to
notice that because he had like one
second on his clock so he played c3 and
now Rick g5 basically wins a pawn I'm
attacking the a5 pawn and he can't play
rook takes b7 because of 96 check now
Walter played a lot of chess in the 70s
and 80s when you sealed moves
adjournments so he's used to thinking a
very long time I'm 41 probably the worst
was coercion oi course never gets in
before you then think almost all of his
time before t1 and crazy if I remember
correctly I think the whole world was
destroyed
oh that's Futurama if I remember
correctly he thought about 45 minutes
here I'm 41 with an hour for the rest of
the game because rook takes pawn wins
upon and then I'm up upon well you guys
don't care you guys at home were like
what's up
on you'll in the dictionary furiously
looking at what upon is grandmasters
don't like lose and puns now in case I
don't win that pond
I got another pot over here I might take
you know what I'm saying
93 96 so now you really started thinking
because he didn't see rugby 5 he thought
I'm going to play 95 and he knew if you
played 95 here and I played rook to c7
the c2 point is hanging
so he's like solid c3 everything's
defended except the a 5 point ok so he
so he played c4 see I didn't make the
joke all the time rook takes a 5 once
again for those of you with short
attention spans rook takes B 7 losses
the rook so played c5 stopping 96-97
again he can't play rook takes fun for a
different reason now his knights hanging
so he defended his knight now I can play
Rick takes p7 except it's not his turn
wrote to b5 if he moves his work away
his b3 puns hanging so he traded Rux and
I'm a pawn up and I like being a pawn up
so I'm the one squeezing and I have 45
minutes left and he has about 6 so he's
having a tough time I defend my B pot
attack his be pawn and usually want to
trade pawns when you're behind because a
knight can't beat nothing but I wanted
to get a passed pawn and my thought was
this pawn will go here his King I'll
stop it and then I'm looking good over
here and that's actually what happened
so I made his King go stop my pawn and
my king came in and I'm pretty proud of
this move Julian in a 1-minute game
before I let go of the night on C one
would play king c3 you agree good move
it's ok you could agree yeah yeah but I
uh I
want to win the night because then I'm
up a night yeah so King III yeah that's
the kind of move when you play it you
know your pawns going to resign because
they're like man that's not good because
you know you're coming you're coming to
get him yeah okay and then he resigned
and he's very gracious very objective
most players when they lose or draw and
they expect to win you know their
behavior is you know their indolence as
and efficacious but Brown was just
saying like yeah I was better than I
wasn't and I went too far and I could
try to draw this any at any time and it
was tough and you know he was right it
was he was better most of the game and
then he tried too hard to win that's the
only game to ever beat Brown and I
played him for a long time 31 years now
of that old if I could count I would let
you know now I put him in 1987 so how
long is that
29 years 28 years what 28 years I'd beat
him once see fool me 27 times shame on
me 28 times shame on you ah well again I
have black every game I think we had
four draws he won two and I won one so
pretty good since I black every game and
he was a far superior player to me until
about the last five years when we're
about to say my guess um but yeah I mean
I want to talk a little bit about his
game with fish replayed fish or ones I
don't want to talk about fish or too
much unless the lectures about Fischer
but Brown was winning that game and by
basically tricking Fischer very good
game they only played the one time and
Fischer avoided losing to Brown by
drawing that game with tricks but also
never playing again so he showed Brown
by quitting chess Brown never got a
chance
Brown never got a chance to beat him
again the one game they did play Fischer
was much better made a mistake Brown had
him and brown let him off the hook at
the end missing a win and playing
something that didn't win but it was a
very good
Brown had a lot of really good games a
lot of really good attacking games he
played in a lot of US Championships if
you want to look up great Brown games I
would look at games against Sarah
wanting Christensen he had a very good
score against erawan and against
Christians and all the games were just
crazy that's the way Larry Plains to and
if somehow I outlive Christensen which
seems really unlikely and I'm the
resident GM here which is even more
unlikely and I do a lecture about
Christensen I mean then we're going to
see some crazy chess so so don't worry
Larry if you kick the bucket it's all
good
like you're going to really have some
good chess to show I don't think any of
these things are going to happen but
Walter and Larry really kindred spirits
as far as very sharp openings
complicated chests and being really
strong into their 50s and 60s
Christensen is not 60 yet but when he is
to be really strong they sort of mind
each other the way they play the
no-nonsense don't care what your
opponent's rating is play for the win
and really going to whisk Walter because
like Larry they're their own person they
do what they want to do and they both
went a lot of Swiss is they both were
2,600 feet a both top in the world and
Larry still play in great chess in his
late 50s and just like Walter did and
there's a lot of great games between
them a lot of great Brown Sarah wine
games
I talked to yes sir a couple years ago I
was going to interview him for chest
life and if he never got published but
they had a good reason I never wrote it
but I asked the answer who was your
toughest opponent throughout the years
and he said olaf anderson and Walter
brown said I can't the antis I just
couldn't play him he just beat me every
game
Walter was usually lower rated than yes
sir but Walter had him and I saw an
interview today at the grand Cup in
Norway and yeah yes it was like man
Walter just had my number we played in
the last round every open tournament
Walter beat me every last round and to
finish I was going to say this earlier
but I was all choked up
and unlike you know John Stewart
actually choked up not pretending yeah
also I'm funny so a lot different than
John Stewart
I was talking to Maurice this morning
where he's actually on the air and he
told me he played Brown the first time
and Brown beat him in 11 moves and you
know the reason that those kind of
things can happen brown's looking to win
right away brown's thinking tactically i
moved one he's calculating he's figuring
it out he's moving his body he's not
like oh it's the first 12 moves a lot of
that i'm not ah he's not doing that and
brown had a lot of wins in less than 20
moves because he was thinking about how
to play great chess and how to win the
game very early not just playing theory
and then i'll play slow positional chess
and winning nine teams he could do that
too but he beat a lot of strong players
in less than 20 moves 11 moves and
Maresa that was the quickest game he's
ever lost I've lost in less than 11
moves but I'm not the one on trial here
so stop stop laughing at me well I hope
you like this lecture and I hope Walters
playing chess in heaven I'm an atheist
but the mysteries of life go Walter
crushed those postures this is
Grandmaster been Feingold with the
legends of chess with Grand Master
Walter Brown